hello welcome to the lobby GameSpot's
weekly Chacho every Tuesday at 2 p.m.
Pacific right here on GameSpot calm I'm
your host Daniel tomorrow and bye Justin
hey world
and Peter Bryan who was thankfully worn
his glasses so that we can tell you two
apart thank you very much gentlemen I've
had people come up to me at Comic Con
last year I had someone come up to me
god I love your work at GameSpot you're
one of my favorite editors and then he
mentioned he was like that video that
you did with with this thing about a
computer and I was like what do you
think my name is you're Peter Brown like
yes I correct Peter Bryan though we're
so happy to have you on so you can tell
us all about u2's favorite Resident Evil
game Revelations 230 you too joke yeah I
do remember that [ __ ] Tomb Raider
song no I have no idea I got my one you
to reference in for this week Resident
Evil Revelations 2 part 1 episode 1
episode 1 I guess this is the first of a
four part Resident Evil sequel to
revelations the tenth game I think and
the Resident Evil franchise yeah well I
don't know wow the core franchise we
just get rid of those light gun games
just put them over there and maybe some
not quite tent if you're going by the
core games there's no Veronica yeah no
yeah we count that
tell me about chapter one because I know
you've played some more but you can only
talk about that once it already went up
on GameSpot today yeah what do you think
of it so far I gave it seven so it's
technically a good great alright that's
our section it's very fitting it's an
episode because Capcom is treating this
like a TV show you know like it it ends
with next week on Resident Evil
Revelations in this and that but but is
next week right yeah they're doing in
weekly episodes and when the last one
comes out you can actually buy the game
you'll get two extra episodes o which is
a bit interesting but anyway you know
it's uh it's good so far as Resident
Evil games go it's certainly not the
scariest it's not the worst either but
it seems to play more into the more
modern Resident Evil's as far as like
camera angles and the way that you go
around below and should I'll share
everything yeah I mean it's the you know
obviously there's no fixed camera angles
and it kind of feels a little bit like
Resident Evil 4 and 5 when it comes to
the action sequences it's not as
over-the-top as six oh god it's a set
between five and six right I'm likewise
possibly your plane is with Moira Burton
Moira Burton and yeah but Claire
Redfield but then also Barry Burton and
a mysterious girl named Natalia mm-hmm
but you basically the gist is is like
there's this company called terra-save
they have this ridiculous corporate
video at the beginning and it's sort of
preface in a party and Claire and Moira
are kidnapped and they wake up in this
this horrible cell and somebody is sort
of orchestrating this big event for them
and they have to try to escape from here
and they just run into like you know
these horrible abominations that are
just trying to murder them and how old
is Moira when you're playing her it's a
good question they don't I don't
actually
they don't say her is she between in
between but she actually works for this
company okay so she's at least 16 okay
but I think she's posed to be more nerd
20s do you think that the the dark
companies in Resident Evil abide by
normal us working laws good question
this one is actually like an inner like
a they're like a front-facing company
that's there to like clean up
bioterrorism grant got it yeah that's
some that time something's gonna do it
and I hear there's some tween ish
cursing in this game yeah something
about a bucket of Fox at some stage
something I care yeah they actually
cleaned it up
since the preview events that we used to
go to I did you ever go to me use any of
those so it was saltier before you have
a soldier before there was this line the
Moira had where she was trying to say
like what the hell is this and when she
really said was what the [ __ ] is that
and they and they capitalize every
letter in the word [ __ ] thankfully they
got rid of that but did they read record
it so like does it like you she said
before like what the [ __ ] is that in it
like someone went back nine oh that
doesn't make sense yes the Reba quit and
I believe they replaced it with one of
the things on my list I had every line
that Moira says where she swears on a
piece of paper in Chapter one in Chapter
one so presumably there's three more
chapters of this of cursing - well I'm
too
two more at least three more oh no
spoilers so does it get better than that
does it get better than what the [ __ ]
which is primo yeah I mean she says
typical things like what the hell are
you doing stuff like that and that's
kind of boring but she has ones where
she says I mean what in the moist barrel
of Fox okay why is it gross but who says
something like a moist barrel of [ __ ]
that's not it doesn't even make sense
she also says who the [ __ ] is quoting
poetry [ __ ] you Hollywood that wasn't
even close to easy also berry can kiss
my ass that guy what is it that guy
[ __ ] and granny swears about
everything
why did she refers to her father as
Barry yeah she doesn't like her dad
apparently but what is granny swearing
you know granny ball like when you you
know you go bowling and you do an
underhand so a great yeah all right so
it's like I've yes I got soft like a
soft lob she's not a granny swear she
said things like you moist bucket of
[ __ ] the last line that she has for it
would be for a moose bucket of farts
because it's brainy square the last line
you hear from her and she's calling me
there I think it might be Wes I'm going
to put this over there she's in a very
desperate situation in his last thing
here Jesus is anyone even out there
[ __ ] [ __ ] on a stick
okay that's how her character closes out
episode 1 great it's just swearing up a
storm and like I don't know she plays an
important role in the plot but otherwise
she just seems like she's there to sort
of be this angsty like young brash
person but I don't think anyone who
wrote this game has ever talked to
anyone does it sound like that it's like
old people writing dialogue totally a
different generation yeah like there are
some that there are some times where she
swears that are fine but for a lot of
times it's such a try-hard right but
then following in the long tradition of
Resident Evil died being completely
ridiculous and funny for the wrong
reasons I'd like to talk about how the
game is good no no get all poor swearing
and I want to represent the good stuff
once you get to play as Barry Burton and
this girl Italia the buddy system gets a
lot better like you have to play with
Moira when you're playing with Claire
she's kind of useless Natalia this young
girl who can kind of sneak by enemies
and they won't notice her there are some
scenes where it's it's actually like a
really scary moment but
berry isn't the right fit even though
he's got like an assault rifle a minigun
yeah in a pistol this young girl this
little tiny girl is like the the right
man for the job and you really do get
that sense of being scared because it's
just sort of like crap I have to use her
but she's so vulnerable and you can't
see what's out there hmm
and so this game does have a few moments
of tension that are really good that do
deliver what I think people who like
Resident Evil games are looking for it's
just kind of stuck in the middle of a
bunch of stuff that's not so great right
so is the game split into two sections
then almost where like your two
different sets of buddies is that how
this plays out yeah so you finished the
section with Claire and Moira and then
it switches to Barry but then that's
great crawl yeah she's good at the
Crouch cross it feels very the Last of
Us in some ways we like when I keep
looking like that and you see that the
young girl's sneaking past yep well
zombies Eve the big guy with huge guns
yeah letting your daughter do all the
work and also Barry Burton sounds
exactly like Liam Neeson and hey why not
he's going to rescue his kidnapped
daughter that's fair enough
there you go excellent so the review for
episode 1 is live on the site will you
be doing reviews every week then for the
next couple week and then I'm gonna do a
review of the entire game right which
will also be there's a boxed version as
well like it's a review I think that's
the only way you get the extra two
episodes I could be wrong you might be
able to buy a season pass that would
make sense but cool right we look
forward to talking to you next week up a
lot of your bad episode 2 and if will
let us know what you think about
Resident Evil Revelations 2 in the
comments below let us know what you
think of moist buckets of [ __ ] yeah
we'll be back next week with an update
on all the curses in the second episode
of that game